they're the big hairy spiders of our
nightmares and it's no wonder we're
afraid tarantulas are the biggest of all
the arachnids these spiders are killing
machines perfectly adapted to their
habitats and the biggest and baddest of
them all is the Goliath it can grow to
nearly a foot across with fangs an inch
long
the Goliath makes its home in the remote
rainforests of South America night is
when the Goliath is most active but for
these ambush predators hunting means
lying in wait near the entrance to her
burrow she lays down a silk welcome mat
it acts like a tripwire letting her know
when something has ventured within range
even with eight eyes Goliath like most
spiders have weak vision they're alerted
to the presence of prey by vibrations
rippling across their sensitive hairs
it's only a matter of time before some
hapless creature like this floor mouse
wanders too close and brushes against
the silk
it's like ringing a dinner bell the
Goliath venom proves fatal to this Mouse
but for most people the tarantulas bite
is no worse than a bee sting according
to researchers there's never been a
single confirmed human death from a
tarantula bite perhaps knowing the facts
about these ancient predators can help
turn human fear into fascination